let's do the worst map in
Counter-Strike okay so Inferno this map
it is just being bombarded by utility
and then the second that you finally
emerge
sunlight just 78 million rad
angles it's genuinely a
nightmare this is where I would put it
Vertigo Vertigo is fantastic it's very
balanced I love taking a ram
dude I love that how like the the room
you have to take fights there are shitty
little off angles but there's also ways
to like actually get people off of off
of angles here and work your way up it's
probably a tier here's the thing about
Dusty chat I think that this map is uh
very bad I loved Dustin before this
bull it happened made it
arguably the most ct-sided map in
Counter-Strike at the absolute highest
it's D new cobblestone
done easy